what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
promotion for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is ramping up we
have a lot of new promos to talk about
today and it looks like we're going to
be getting a clip of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness during the
super bowl marvel always shows something
for an upcoming project during the super
bowl and right now word has it that it
is going to be for multiverse of madness
and possibly even a moon knight teaser
as well word has it that these are just
going to be clips scenes from the movie
not actual trailers but still very
exciting nonetheless and hopefully this
clip will give us a little bit more
details about what to expect for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness in
the meantime marvel has recently
released some promo images for
multiverse of madness and they show
different variants of dr strange now we
know who at least one of these variants
are we're gonna talk about who the
second variant could be and it also kind
of looks like a group is being formed in
multiverse of madness a multiversal
group that could be the illuminati the
illuminati finally in the mcu but
different than the comics we're gonna
talk about all of this and break it down
in this video and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news now first
things first with the new promo art we
have a new look at the scarlet witch
she's dressed in her full outfit
including her crown and if you look in
her hands we can see chaos magic now
rumors have been flying that she could
be the villain or one of the villains of
this film and i have to think that this
photo right here does look kind of
villainesque do i think she's going to
be the true villain of the film and
threaten the world not entirely but i do
think she'll be looking for her children
and she'll stop at nothing to get them
this may make her butt heads with
strange and may make them fight a little
bit but i don't think she's going to be
the true villain then there's some promo
art in the shape of a comic book cover
that is really cool and then we have a
new character this character's name is
rentra now rin rintra in the comics is
good who knows what role he'll have in
multiverse of madness but at least in
the comics he is a good character in
fact he helps doctor strange a few times
and he helps him defeat erthona and he
also helped wang and topaz because they
were being held captive by orthona he
helps doctor strange a few times and
eventually asks him to become his
apprentice and eventually doctor strange
agrees so we could be looking at a
magical apprentice here the only
question is is he from our universe is
he partnered up with are doctor strange
or is he an apprentice of another doctor
strange in a different universe because
as we can see by these next few photos
there are going to be multiple variants
of doctor strange in the film now in
this first photo at the very top we can
see a normal doctor strange on the right
side we can see the doctor strange that
was in the trailer at the end where he
says things just got out of hand and
we'll talk about him in just a bit
because we're not 100 sure who this
doctor strange variant is yet but i will
say he
he does sound kind of evil
things just got out of hand
and mordo does say that the greatest
threat to the multiverse is doctor
strange perhaps he is referring to his
variant but let's talk about this other
variant of doctor strange the one on the
bottom who i know to be defender strange
how do we know this is defender strange
well there was a toy leak a while ago
that came out that said defender strange
on it and it looks exactly like this one
right here and we actually do see
defender strange in the trailer very
very briefly in a blink and you'll miss
it moment he can be distinguished
because he has white strips on the side
of his hair but on the top of his head
not the side of his head like the normal
doctor strange and he has a ponytail
with the sides of his head shaved if you
look closely in this scene you could see
him
it's hard to make out but the ponytail
is a dead giveaway you can also see the
white streaks on the side of his head
now who are these two variants of doctor
strange well let's start with defender
strange now as one would think defender
strange is probably good because of his
title defender now what is he defending
well most likely the multiverse this
variant of doctor strange probably knows
a lot more about the multiverse than our
normal doctor strange does anything is
possible perhaps he's a variant of
doctor strange who actually didn't get
snapped so maybe he had that five years
to discover the multiverse or perhaps in
his universe the events of thanos never
even happened at all or maybe he's in
the universe where star-lord didn't lose
his mind and punch thanos and ruin
everything regardless i do believe he is
defending the multiverse and knows more
about it than our current doctor strange
now the question is who is he defending
the multiverse from and i believe this
to be the other strange i really hope
that the main villain of this film is a
doctor strange variant and it does
appear to be that way one like i
mentioned the dude sounds evil and he
really looks evil now this could be
misdirection on marvel's part but we
also do hear the words of mordo saying
that the greatest threat to their
universe is you speaking to doctor
strange why is doctor strange the
greatest threat to the multiverse is it
because he was tampering with his own
universe now that could be it but for
something to cause the entire multiverse
to collapse it seems like it would have
to be way bigger than just doctor
strange making everybody forget who
spider-man is the threat is most likely
doctor strange in general in any type of
universe because he has the knowledge
and ability to actually tamper with the
multiverse and i think we're seeing two
different sides of doctor strange here
well three if you count our main one but
the defender strange side and what looks
to be an evil side of doctor strange now
this could be sorcerer supreme strange
could it be the one from what if it is a
possibility the executive producers over
at marvel did hint that what if could
and kind of hinted that it will cross
over into live action mcu and in the
very beginning of the doctor strange
trailer where everything is kind of
floating up into the sky in darkness
that looks like exactly what happened in
the what if series and in that episode
the universe that supreme strange messed
with did ultimately collapse so perhaps
we are dealing with a strange supreme
here and maybe he's not evil but i'm
thinking that he is now it looks like
these two variants of doctor strange are
going to be pretty prominent characters
in the movie because they have at least
four promotional posters released for
them so far all showing the three
different doctor stranges our main one
and then defender strange and we'll call
him sorcerer supreme strange it's very
clear that in all of these photos they
are the same people and it really would
make sense if there was one good one
evil and one neutral are doctor strange
now as far as defender strange goes i
actually think something really cool is
happening with him because i think that
he is from a different universe and he
is aware of the other doctor strange's
tampering with the multiverse and i
think that he is part of a universal
group that monitors threats to the
entire multiverse almost like the tva
but i don't think this group is ran by
some big organization i think it's ran
by the heroes of the multiverse a group
of heroes that have come together to
protect the entire multiverse almost
like an illuminati but for the
multiverse and i think here's where
we're going to see some of the other
variants of other heroes come into play
yes we'll probably see many different
cameos as the characters go through
different universes here and there but
i'm talking about prominent cameos a lot
of people really want tom cruise to show
up as an iron man variant perhaps we
could see him there perhaps we could see
john krasinski as mr fantastic another
fan favorite that everybody wants right
now heck robert downey jr could return
as tony stark he could look the same but
just be a little bit different anything
is possible and then hopefully we get
some x-men involved in there as well but
i do believe that there is a group that
is responsible for looking after the
multiverse and i think defender strange
is from that group and i think he runs
into our doctor strange because he's
hunting the evil doctor strange but
hopefully the next trailer or tv spot
that we get gives us a little bit of
insight on what to expect in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you